ladies and gentlemen we are back from
the time skip and about to dive
headfirst into shippuden something i've
noticed since starting this series is
that unlike any other series i've
covered fans seem divided and that's
putting it lightly since i finished the
very first arc of this series with every
subsequent video i keep getting comments
saying something along the lines of it's
all downhill from here which having now
completed the first arc of shippuden i
can't say i share that opinion yet
anyway some parts i might like more than
others but i haven't noticed a decline
of anything noteworthy so far the story
seems to flow very well with a clear
vision behind it of what needs or wants
to be done i'm not saying that it can't
go downhill from here but it hasn't
happened for me yet and it certainly
didn't happen with this arc and today
i'm sharing my blind first impressions
of the kazukage rescue mission and
spoiler alert i loved it
[Music]
before i dive into this week's material
i have something to announce like many
of you i've been a fan of spider-man
since i was five years old it was the
movie that inspired me to start looking
at film as an art form and now having
grown up i happen to have a channel
where i review stories i love for your
entertainment i had planned on taking
december off this year but instead i had
an idea spider-man no way home hits
theaters this december 17th and so i
thought it might be fun if this december
we go full spider themed in a challenge
i am dubbing spidey sember i'm very
proud of the name within which i will
attempt to review and break down some of
the most iconic and heavily criticized
live-action spider-man films ever to be
released i'm talking garfield i'm
talking toby i'm talking tom holland
these reviews will be contained to three
videos released on december 2nd december
9th and with the final review dropping
december 16th one day before the release
of spider-man no way home one of the
most hotly anticipated films in
superhero film history i'll be kicking
things off this by december with the
raimi trilogy on december 2nd which i
hadn't seen since i was a kid in
theaters i can't wait to share my
feelings on these films that changed my
life and i hope to see you all there for
this spidey sember
the further i've delved into this series
the more i found that it likes to
utilize fights to tell its story while i
do like this approach and i think it
makes sense given the circumstances i do
think that overall it does feel a lot
more one note in its approach compared
to earlier arcs which had opportunities
for training and exams to filter the
themes and narrative contexts for
different characters however with that
said i also think that the conversations
that occur during these fights serve as
a nice balance to that issue and lack of
variety in certain settings this arc
which focuses on the reintroduction of
all the main and secondary characters
primarily concerns itself with the
kidnapping of gara and the bringing full
circle of his character arc it's a
powerful tale with themes of
responsibility regret and loneliness in
terms of the new post-time skip designs
while many of the secondary characters
have remained much the same i do enjoy
the reimagined designs of naruto and
sakura there's an obvious air of
maturity to these respective looks
helped enormously by the addition of
darker colours on naruto removing some
of the fiery orange with a much more
muted darker tone the same goes for
sakura i love that she's decided to keep
her hair short which speaks to her
mindset greatly thanks to the fight she
had with ino during the tuning exams
furthermore her outfit similar to her
more mature persona reflects a more
practical action-based approach
stripping away her dress-like garments
replacing them with something far more
fitting i think i'm particularly happy
with this change in sakura which i will
definitely touch more on later in this
video with her outstanding fight but as
far as first impressions go i'm honestly
thrilled that sakura has been training
under lady tsunade managing in her own
way to find an identity in a critically
important vertical the likes of which
naruto and sasuke aren't good at it
plays to the natural strengths she
demonstrates as a character in the first
part and builds upon them naturally
giving me a sense that she is in fact
her own character
as a concept i really love time skips
and stories they can't really be used
all too often and when used correctly
can offer a lot of anticipation and fun
for the audience reading or watching a
great example of this is once again one
piece where before the time skip
everyone had a clear motivation a clear
set goal to aim for in the time they had
to train and once they return after the
time skip we anticipate the reveal of
how each person did during their time
away dragon ball on the other hand took
a different approach by effectively
ending on a high note at the end of the
23rd tenkaichi budokai and when they
picked back up in the saiyan arc they
communicated the passage of time
visually through either the action
between goku and raditz or through goku
now having a young son called gohan to
be clear i'm not saying either of those
approaches to the time skip are unique
and i'm certainly not suggesting that
kishimoto looked to mirror his approach
after any one of these i mean this arc
of naruto was written in 2006 well
before the time skip of one piece i'm
just using these as examples of how one
might approach this narrative mechanic
and make it work for them interestingly
though the naruto series seems to have
taken an approach similar to but not
exactly the same as either of them
similar to one piece in that naruto's
final arc before the time skip ends in a
tragic manner and spurred on from the
results of that our heroes now have a
clear-cut goal to work towards and like
dragon ball we see the passage of time
with certain characters more accurately
through the revelation of their new
circumstances while we can see the
developments and improvements of naruto
and sakura with extreme clarity during
their introduction training sessions
with kakashi we also see the new
position gara finds himself in now that
the dust has settled and as it happens
this arc concerns itself with his story
greatly
[Applause]
finally after all this time the akatsuki
are making their presence felt and in
this arc they are pretty damn awesome
itachi specifically i found to be
massively entertaining in that regard
creepy as it was but i'll touch on that
a little later as it happens these
akitsuki folks are after individuals
known as jin churiki these are humans
like gara and naruto that within them
possess a spirit of one of the
nine-tailed beast b-spirit things and
speaking of which one of this arc's
strongest reintroductions comes by way
of gara to the story we catch up with
him in the sand village he was raised in
as the new kazakage the differences
don't stop there however and we see just
how much he's changed when a character
from the akatsuki arrives and starts to
slaughter the people of his village
there are flashbacks detailing in
explicit terms how gara's mindset has
changed over the last number of years
dedicating himself to his people he
wants to build a connection with his
village gain the respect and to become
something precious to them he wants to
be a person people can look up to
someone who can lead and look after his
community it's a beautiful 180 he's
taken since we last saw him during the
tuning exams with my favorite
demonstrations of his character coming
in the form of his defense of his own
village using all of his chakra in a
massive effort shielding his people from
the oncoming attacks from deidara and i
don't know what it is but every single
time gara tangos with anyone it's always
expectable something amazing to look at
visually while offering up some juicy
narrative growth in the process the
fight that takes place while not being
much to look at in the anime in the
manga the page spreads are truly
breathtaking the scale is evident that
only further serves to reinforce the
extreme effort gara is willing to push
himself towards in the name of
protecting others now despite the fight
ending in defeat for the young kazukage
it's clear that gara is on the path to
winning the war in his mind helped
obviously by the young uzumaki naruto's
actions and philosophy however now
kidnapped and in transit to the
stronghold of the akatsuki for purposes
we have yet to fully understand the word
reaches naruto and his allies something
needs to be done and this my friends is
where our story really kicks off but
before i jump into naruto and the gang's
effort to catch up with and save gara i
have one small nitpick that i just have
to get out in the open there have been
very few things in naruto the series
that have bothered me and honestly fewer
than is standard for a story i review on
a long term basis however now i think is
the time to talk about a particularly
bad piece of writing that's all over
this manga it's minor but it would be
disingenuous for me not to mention it
amongst all the praise i've given this
series my pet peeve with this series is
when a character says and i quote
that jutsu you know when in movies
characters that are best friends tell us
that they're best friends like hey man
we've been friends since we were kids
etc etc people don't really speak to
each other like that in the real world
and it just sucks me out of the
experience when i hear it or see it in
writing and in a sense that's what that
jutsu does for me when a character says
it to another you can't be talking about
that jutsu it's i mean like they may as
well be winking at the camera now with
that said i totally understand the
utility of such a sentence kishimoto
wants to tell us that whomever speaking
has an ace up their sleeve but he
doesn't want to tell us what that is i
get it it's a builder of anticipation in
a sense but there has to be a better way
than this and to be honest it wouldn't
have bothered me if it only been once or
twice in the series but it happens
countless times alright so back to the
story once word reaches naruto back at
the village lady tsunade sends himself
sakura and kakashi to check it out their
mission is to suss out the situation in
the stand village and report back
immediately before there's any trouble
one thing i will say though is that once
they do arrive sakura demonstrates how
impressive she is with her abilities to
heal the wounded and cure poison there's
now such a pronounced contrast with her
particularly when you compare her with
the comparatively much less competent
child she was when the series began and
this isn't by any means all she's
improved since these days but we'll get
to that soon furthermore before we go
into the final act of the story i do
want to say that i really enjoyed the
wild cards that were injected into the
mix right before the second half of this
arc out of nowhere a guy's team with
everyone's favorite little splendid
ninja rock lee is roped into this
mission kakashi and his team decide to
try and retrieve gara from those that
stole him away and it's something naruto
is very passionate about pursuing and in
that pursuit trouble finds them
itachi is [ __ ] terrifying
but you know what isn't terrifying
audible the sponsor of this video i love
analyzing these wonderful stories and if
you've been watching for a while you
know i adore my books on narrative
theory km wannan's book on character
arcs is one of my all-time favorites
what if there were a sure-fire secret to
creating stunning character arcs
would you be interested in discovering
it well i was and you can be too thanks
to audible your membership gives you
access to many thousands of audio books
podcasts and even guides for fitness
which honestly is great for me seeing as
i'm trying to run a marathon next year
as an audible member you get one credit
each month that you can spend on any of
the premium titles that's all the latest
new releases download one of those a
month and you get to keep it forever you
also get access to the new plus catalog
which hosts awesome things like ad free
podcasts thousands upon thousands of
older audiobooks and audible's great
original programs so why not treat
yourself this holiday whether you're
sitting cozily around the fireplace or
driving around to see family audible's a
wonderful partner for this time of year
for a limited time you can join for only
7.95
a month that's saving you a whopping 46
percent on your first four months of
audible go to audible.com forward slash
not mark link down in the description or
text not mark to 500 500 that's
audible.com forward slash not mark and
hey new members get 30 days entirely for
free
[Music]
i think what i like most about this
section which doesn't just depict
itachi's fight with kakashi's group but
also guy's team with hitachi's ally
kisame isn't simply just how imposing
the enemies are presented but how
capable the leaders of each group are
kakashi and guy there's some great lines
of dialogue from kakashi here that
really helped to relax me into this
situation revealing itachi's strategy
his weaknesses with his eyesight and
threatening him by saying that he
kakashi doesn't make the same mistakes
twice almost putting himself on the same
level as hitachi and reminding us all
too that he was a prodigy when he was
growing up and really i think despite
the two fights happening side by side
with different people guy and kakashi
they share a ton in common with both
leaders groups suffering compromises to
their abilities leaving much of the
heavy lifting to guy and kakashi
respectively guy ends up implementing a
technique very similar to that which lee
used against gara and in the manga the
scenes feel truly massive the scope of
the battle feels enormous which
interestingly is the exact opposite of
kakashi's fight with hitachi and this is
by design it felt painfully intimate
everything from hitachi's first
appearance to his constant state of
always feeling comfortable in every
situation i mean this is why kakashi in
this instance added so much to the scene
with hitachi popping up out of the
shadows the reassurance kakashi gave me
as a reader felt much needed but good
god did i not anticipate what he would
put naruto through acting as some sort
of sadistic spirit of christmas past
confronting him with manifestations of
his deepest insecurities regrets and
fears it's a masterful touch further
separating itachi as a villain or foe
unlike any we've seen before in this
story clay maxing in a sequence where
kakashi holds hitachi off long enough
for sakura to bring naruto back to
reality where he lands a devastatingly
impressive attack in his feral spirit
state and it's the combination of this
in tandem with his shadow clone
technique that made this hype as all
hell and that's when hitachi and kasami
reveal that these were fakes the entire
time and that their real selves aren't
anywhere close by appearing before them
like this simply because they wish to
stall them frustrating as it was for
sure it was also a brilliant scene and
one that really freaked me out while i
was reading it
all right so the situation is big door
has a lock gar is on the other side
being killed and because of that door
and the seal that's on it they have to
split up into a bunch of different
fights some are great and others we
straight up just do not see so let's
kick things off with one of the battles
that we do see the battle inside the
cave featuring granny chio and sakura vs
sassori
sakura's fight with lady chio against
cesari was actually way way better than
i was anticipating sakura while showing
promise in a multitude of areas always
felt significantly less interesting due
in part to her being used predominantly
for comedy and well to swoon over sasuke
which again that's totally normal for a
young girl in a story to do but when all
of the other characters have deeply
philosophical and moral dilemmas at the
core of their respective characters that
they themselves deal with in every fight
it really felt like when different
battles took place sakura was left out
to dry but in this arc kishimoto seems
to have given her something much more to
work with or at the very least build
something significant off of the strong
foundations laid during certain sections
of prior arcs characters like kakashi
rock lee gara hinata neji naruto and
even sasuke all derive their issues from
their upbringings however compared to
these characters
sakura's upbringing was comparatively
painless and well normal i mean in the
first arc when she was introducing and
presenting herself in the first arc she
defined herself by what at the time was
most important to her sasuke but fast
forward to right now after the time skip
she can now derive ambition and
motivation not from her childhood but
from the events that took place over the
course of the series as first half stuff
that we the readers can relate to she's
now full of regret after she failed to
keep sasuke from fleeing the village in
the first place disappointed that she
was too weak to help bring him home and
now years later she's trained to become
significantly stronger studying under
lady tsunade to gain jutsu to
specifically protect and heal her
friends and in this scene she fights
tooth and nail against cesare just so
that she can live up to her own ideals
one moment longer i've been critical in
the past tour but i also give credit
where it's due and that right there
that's a tremendous improvement on all
fronts at numerous points in this fight
sakura is told to stand down to let the
old lady handle this fight and time and
time again she picks herself off the
ground and shows everyone including us
the readers that she isn't the same
scared little girl she once was and
really while she started the story as
this girl i was sort of only lukewarm on
this fight alongside granny cheo acts as
at least for me her coronation as a
fully realized character with a
wonderful resolve clearly on display
struggling with her own internal
psychological questions unique to her by
the way and a master that sees something
inside her student that no one else
seems to see where sasuke has his clans
genetics or heritage and naruto has the
fox spirit it's easy to forget that
sakura doesn't have these same
advantages and for her to become as
exceptional as she is right here is a
feat worth standing back and showing
praise for
couple this with the fact that her
opponent says sorry and her partner
chiyo and you have for yourself a
narrative cocktail primed for some
effective emotional imagery and a
challenge large enough to allow sakura
to amaze us all with her new abilities
as jio is faced with aggression against
her own lost grandson having totally
lost his way by the way starved of the
love that he cherished and so needed
uses his powers of puppetry to wield the
parents he lost as a child it's
unsettling and it's tragic particularly
when you take into account the fashion
with which chio and sakura see to his
demise using the puppets of his parents
assuming the same positions around him
as they symbolically welcome him to the
afterlife stabbing him collectively in
the same pose they were seen hugging him
once before this event also concerned
itself with chio considerably i found
her character quite abrasive and well
unlikable when we were introduced to her
but she too has undergone a considerable
change one that is linked in many ways
to gara and his standing in his
community and speaking of gara time to
finally check in with the character
leading the charge for his rescue
naruto the more this series explores
naruto as a character the more
interesting he becomes to me since the
beginning of this series we haven't
really had much chance to see kakashi
show naruto much attention but that
changes in this arc and with that change
something came into focus for me a theme
i don't often see explored in as much
depth and honest of fashion is that of
responsibility within shonen's stories
now i know what you're going to say
that's sort of the crux of like 90
percent of various characters and to
that i say i appreciate and understand
that but within those stories often
times if the outcome of a rash decision
made by a character results in
confrontation or aggression
normally stories will lean more in the
camp of determination and tenacity to
save the day for that character which
sort of flies in the face of the theme
of responsibility i think in a sense
naruto desperately wants to save sasuke
he desperately wants to save gara it's
as clear as day on his face his
frustration and anger is bubbling to the
surface as he brandishes his fox
spirit's powers more and more he
promised sakura he promised everyone and
he promised himself that he would bring
back gara home and yet at numerous
points in this arc he loses his temper
and finds himself either compromising
his team's effort or their well-being
forcing us to contend with the notion
that if naruto truly would do anything
to bring them back then he would also
deny himself this indulgence into
violence and revenge that he so clearly
desperately is pushing for all in the
name of creating the best possible
chance to save gaara in this instance
perhaps more times in this arc than we
have seen in any arc prior naruto has
assumed his feral state eyes and claws
poised for an animalistic attack to try
and force his way to gara perhaps with
his failings in helping sasuke echoing
in his mind also but the point is that
his intentions are good but he must know
that that's not the best way and yet he
indulges in it regardless this is why i
love kakashi because in this chase he
grounds the young ninja reaffirming to
him that they are indeed in the same
team and that if he wants gara back they
just need to be smart about how they
approach this altercation with daedara
and you know what's interesting about
this particular mechanic with naruto is
that as it happens the more he loses
himself to the spirit the more this
behavior invokes its power and the more
of a risk he runs in not only never
achieving his goal but he might lose
himself completely also thanks to his
friendships with the likes of jireiah
and kakashi he's managed to avoid this
but i just find it interesting that this
power which he draws from if drawn from
too much will run counter to what his
ultimate goals are and nothing drives
that home more
than this
there's a simple but fantastic series of
panels in this manga where gara finds
himself all alone fading away with no
one to help him and simply naruto
someone who's found himself in that same
situation thinks of the times when he
was at his loneliness eventually he
slowly but surely built a community
around him that cared about him it's
been described in the story and
particularly in this arc that naruto's
power is to build connections with
everyone he speaks with and this is
reflected in these panels as time went
on he was able to build around him a
wonderful community of friends and loved
ones but gara didn't have those same
advantages and when chio starts to make
murmurings along the lines of this is
how it is for kazakh naruto snaps
no one understands gara like naruto does
and even naruto can't imagine what his
circumstances must have been like
interestingly there's something of a
contradiction at play here where much of
the drama seems to be stemming from in a
very natural and great way mind you in
how naruto feels in relation to gara
versus how the rest of the world seems
to treat ninjas and certainly jinshiriki
they are disposable and yet in this
outburst with the death of gaara despite
wanting to be hokage one of the highest
positions in this structure
he seems beside himself totally and
utterly distraught at the notion that no
one ever considered how he might have
felt how gaara might have felt how his
life might have gone different had he
not been forced to connect with this
spirit in the first place in other words
naruto's here to shake things up he
wants to become hokage and maybe he'll
change this crazy world along the way
this show of emotion and frankly common
sense resonates with the old-timer and
in a last-ditch effort to do what she
believes is the right thing to do she
sacrifices herself to bring gara back
from the brink and the depiction of
which is beautiful surrounded by those
he longed for connection with gara now
has a family who loves him men okay look
it's a great story shippuden is off to a
great start and hopefully the next stop
will be itachi or sasuke or something
along those lines but for now thanks for
stopping by and checking out this review
i'll be covering the next arc next week
and after that we have spidey sember if
you don't want to miss any of these
reviews i encourage you to subscribe for
more i've recently realized that less
than half of you who watch my channel
are subscribed so what's up with that
just hit the button it'll take like a
second it'll be no effort and it'll make
me super happy but that'll do it for
this week love you guys and thank you so
much for watching
[Music]
in the mountains